mais l'abbé cieux j'aimerais vous parler
ce soir d'un sujet d'actualité
la déprime
la déprime oui tiens parlons-en un peu à
travers des archives de la télé qu'en
vieillissant on est tous confrontés une
forme de dépression inévitable
cette baisse de moral elle s'accentue
surtout l'automne et l'hiver à mesure
que les nuits rallonge oh ça va moyen
peut dire est que le froid s'installe
pour y remédier et quelques traitements
d'abord quelques notes de musique voici
stepan reggiani c'était en 1974 le titre
du morceau la déprime tout simplement en
latin
la déprime
il n'aimait pas
entouré mots
on l'appelait
la déprime il avait une drôle de fring
dans son post une manoeuvre l'eau
soit parce que je sais tu pas que rim à
la déprime ça va un peu mieux mende
rebonds n'ont toujours pas bon on
continue autre remède l'humour bien sûr
avec un sketch de dany boon en 1996
l'humoriste joue le dépressif et vous
allez le voir il a sa petite technique
pour en terminer avec le blues de
l'hiver
ça vient uniquement du fait que vous
vous avez pris la mauvaise habitude de
son plein j'ai dit vous parce que madame
c'est
au moins ça c'est clair après la musique
et l'humour voici un troisième et
dernière antidote offerts par nos soins
le club de rire je suis blanche neige et
j'attendais cette main
pour lutter contre la déprime hivernale
nos voisins allemands ont la solution
chaque semaine et c'est le même rituel
ce groupe se rassemble et rient à gorge
déployée
je vous mets des fermes ici je me
recharge les batteries pour toute la
semaine parce qu'à la maison on a perdu
le sens du rire depuis 2005 la déprime à
même sa journée le blue monday qui tombe
chaque troisième lundi de janvier si ce
jour si vous n'avez pas le moral c'est
normal cette date serait tout simplement
la plus déprimante de l'année selon un
calcul d'un psychologue britannique m'a
fait un sourire je sais pas
[Musique]